zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans zone Europe
sur Radio sensation une émission
enregistrée au Parlement européen de
Strasbourg en association avec TV 78 un
flashback pour commencer Jersey buzec a
occupé la présidente du Parlement
européen du 14 juillet 2009 au 17
janvier 2012 retour sur son parcours
avec Alberto bevilhaca chargé de mission
à Europe Direct Seine-et-Marne vitam
chose qui me saoule bonjour les
auditeurs aujourd'hui un petit clin
d'oeil à nos amis polonaises et polonais
pour introduire un personnage qui a joué
un rôle majeur pour l'Union européenne
du nouveau millénaire et emblématique
d'une Europe de l'Est ayant été au cœur
de l'histoire une histoire mouvementée
mais avec la puissante volonté de se
soulever pour la démocratie